do you have an exercise or anything you
do before you go on stage because I know
that I did improv years ago and andg
started out in improv
some people have actual techniques they
do to sort of help them warm up before
they go on stage
there was one exercise that they used to
have us do in an improv class and it was
this exercise called give me back my son
and have you ever seen the movie ransom
with Mel Gibson yeah yeah okay so in
that movie Mel Gibson's son is kidnapped
and there's one very dramatic scene
where he's on the phone with his son's
captors and he goes get me back my son
he's really red-faced and angry and so
the exercise the way the exercise worked
is you would like walk up to somebody in
the class and you'd make eye contact and
you would have to with full rage and
intensity say my son and hold eye
contact and and not laugh and then they
would do it to the next person so how
does it work how do you get eliminated
if you laugh laugh you can't laugh so
you have to commit even though you're
anxious you feel embarrassed there is no
more awkward thing to do than to walk up
to another adult scream give me back my
son and hold their gate I mean would you
like to try it I think
[Applause]
I think the critical thing is you have
to have like full like all of the anger
and as your son's been taken right so
just say I get it
okay so I if you should go first you
want to go first sure all right
[Applause]
so real it was sweet I'm she doesn't
even like it something now what do I do
okay so okay so you look me in the eye
yeah and then whenever you're ready let
fly given that my son
[Applause]
all right wait do you want to do it
again it's just can we do speed routes
[Applause]
laughing out I'm trying to pass out what
we're learning is in applies a sociopath
[Applause]
I feel that was like the happiest
nightmare yeah it's just two guys who
are very confused about who has whose
son yeah turns out our kids are just
over there having ice cream so I messed
up the carpool
you